this is the fifth video in my clean code
series based on Ryan McDermott's article
this series is about how to write clean
code that is readable reusable and
reflectable now I will talk about
classes it's always better to write
small functions than classes but if you
do need a class you should use es6
classes instead of how classes are
created in es5 especially if you need
inheritance so let me show you how an
es5 what a class looks this is the bad
way to do it so here is how you used to
do it when you were using ES 5 if you
want an inheritance I'm not going to go
through all the details because again
this is not how we want to do it but we
would create an animal and this is how
you would create the animal class and
you could add a move function to it and
if you wanted to inherit from the animal
class you're gonna create mammal and you
are going to have to call the animal
class with impasse in the age but then
if you want to add a fur color to the
mammal that's different than the animal
class and then stop fur color you are
going to create this the prototype based
on the animal class you are going to
create what the constructor is basically
there's a lot of different steps pretty
long compared to what you will see for
the es6 class so let me show you what
the es6 class would look like and i just
pasted that in and you can see this is
much shorter this is the whole thing
right here and it's so it's a lot more
readable this ef6 class is a lot more
readable then you see what this is 5
class looks like so we're going to
create the class animal constructor or
you pass in the age you're gonna have
the function move which is not defined
in this example but we have the mammal
which is going to extend animal that's
how you're going to do inheritance and
even a super age which passes in the age
here they create the fur color create
the
birth function that's in the mammal
class but not the animal class then we
have the human class which extends
mammal class you're going to pass in
three things in the constructor but it's
going to do super-agent fur color well
this is just going to call the the
previous function the mammal function
which is then going to passed age to
this function then you're going to
create your new language spoken variable
here and you create you can create a new
function here basically the point is
that it's just a lot easier to read now
let's go on to method chaining method
chaining allows your code to be more
expressive and less verbose the easiest
way to explain method chaining is just
to show you so first I'm going to show
you what it would look like without
method chaining now this is the bad way
to do it so if you create a class and
you're gonna have a constructor here and
this is some of the default values and
then you can also have these function
where you can set the make you can set
the model you can set the color and then
you would save the class using this
function which is not the save is not
fully implemented but just as an example
it's going to consult log these things
when you're creating a car class you can
view Const car equals new car car that
set color pink car data set color for
peridot set model f150 and then car
let's save now let me show you what it
would look like with chaining it's
mainly this part right here that it's
going to be a lot simpler so let me put
in the good way which is how you do
method chaining now when you're creating
a function with method chaining you're
just going to return this at the end of
every function so everything is the same
in this new class car except we have
this line at the end of each function
we're going to return this we're going
to return this we're gonna return this
we're gonna return this and this allows
us to do something different first let
me show you what it used to look like
when you were you're creating a car we
were saying that we do car that's that
color colors that make cutouts that
model cut out save now since we've
returned the
object at the end of each function we
can just do this we don't have to do car
that's that car that's that make karna
set model we can just do dot set color
pink dot set make dot set model and dot
set save because up here after the
function is is run it's going to just
return undefined and then when you try
to call another function if we did set
color pink and then we put dot set make
without putting the car here it's going
to say that it cannot call this function
on undefined because we're not returning
that car again at the end of the
function but when we return this at the
end of each function if after it sets
the code of pink it's going to return
the car object so on that same car
object you can set the make and then you
can set the model and then we're just
chaining the methods one after the other
okay the last thing I want to talk about
is that you should prefer composition
over inheritance inheritance is like
what we did up here where we did mammal
extends animal human extends mammal
that's inheritance humanism hitting from
mammal mammal ISM hitting from animal
composition is when you have one class
that's referenced from another class but
you don't necessarily extend that class
I'll show you an example but it's good
to know that there are actually good
reasons to use inheritance and good
reasons to use composition but you
should try to use composition over
inheritance when possible well let me
show you an example the composition and
inheritance so it'll be the bad way to
do it with composition and so what we're
gonna create the class employee which is
gonna have this constructor name an
email and then we're gonna create the
class employee tax data and say extends
employee so employee tax data is
inheriting from employee but
right here this is bad because employees
have text data employee texting is not a
type of employee and you're going to use
composition when you have it has a
relationship like employees has a or
have tax data you can use inheritance
when you have an is a relationship like
a human is a animal or is an animal if
you want to add tax data you're not just
going to extend employ and add the tax
data here you are going to use
composition so let me show you what that
would look like
so in this composition example you're
still going to have two classes so first
we're going to define the employee tax
data class with the social security
number and salary and then we're going
to define the employee class but not in
other classes are going to extend from
another class we are just going to use
the employee tax data class within the
employee class so it says set tax data
and a social security number in salary
this is just a function or a method of
the employee class and we are going to
say this duck taxed air equals new
employee tax data social security number
and salary so we are just calling this
class from within this other class and
that's how you would do composition oh
whoops this was supposed to say that
this is a good way to do it now there
are some good reasons to use inheritance
even though it's as bad up here it you
just have to think through what you are
your actual problem is so if you have an
is a relationship then you should use
inheritance like the human is a animal
like I said or but if you have a has a
relationship like if you have user and
user details a user is not user details
but user has a detail then you would use
composition also you should use a
heritance if you can reuse code from
base classes like humans can move like
all animals and the third reason why you
would want to use inheritance is that if
you can if you want to make global
changes to derive classes
by changing a base class well that's
clean code classes thanks for watching
my name is beau Carnes don't forget to
subscribe and remember use your code for
good